[Aplausos]
bueno y yo quiero contarle la historia
del descubrimiento que a lo menos yo
considero el más relevante de mi carrera
hasta ahora y ha sido un resultado
totalmente fortuito y del que yo he
aprendido varias lecciones y son
especialmente estas la que quiero
compartir bueno y estudio nuestra
galaxia la vía láctea
esto es una imagen de cómo se ve la vía
láctea desde un cielo muy oscuro como lo
que tenemos por ejemplo en el norte de
chile es una franja hecha por manchones
brillantes que son las estrellas y
manzone oscuros que son la nube de gas y
polvo al estar nosotros por la tierra el
sol metido dentro de la vía láctea
podemos estudiar con muchísimo detalle
sus estrellas y los telescopios modernos
nos dan la posibilidad de hacer un zoom
in hasta las regiones más centrales de
nuestra galaxia y así resolver por
ejemplo los manchones brillantes en
estrellas individuales que podemos
estudiar con mucho detalle y también
utilizando luz infrarroja podemos
penetrar lo manzone oscuro la nube de
polvo e ir hacia estudiar las estrellas
que están escondidas detrás
pero lo que ningún telescopio ni
presente ni futuro nos va a poder
permitir hacer es la operación opuesta
hacer el summa out que necesitaríamos
para poder ver cómo se vería nuestra
galaxia desde afuera entonces dicho en
otras palabras estamos metido acá
adentro podemos ver los árboles las
plantitas pero nos cuesta mucho ver el
bosque nos cuesta mucho saber qué forma
tiene qué estructura tiene nuestra
galaxia
pese a estas dificultades hoy en día
sabemos que la vía láctea es una galaxia
espiral gigante muy parecida a ésta está
una imagen real de otra galaxia y hemos
podido construir un mapa bastante
detallado de cómo se vería nuestra
galaxia desde afuera en el caso de
nuestra galaxia este mapa solamente
puede ser un dibujo artístico por lo que
mencionamos antes entonces sabemos que
la mayoría de las estrellas en nuestra
galaxia están en un disco este disco
tiene brazos dos de ellos muy bien
desarrollados otros menores y tiene una
gran concentración de estrella en su
parte central que llamamos bulbo que es
alargada como una barra el sol está a
mitad de camino el disco ahora este mapa
tiene cierto porcentaje de fantasía
porque por ejemplo la parte que está
detrás del bulbo con respecto al sol no
la podemos ver entonces ahí la dibujamos
con cierta
vida y otra cosa que no sabemos muy bien
hasta el día de hoy es cómo se forman
esta estructura tan grande cómo se
forman las galaxias una cosa que nos
ayuda a entender cómo se forman la
galaxia una de las muchas es medir la
composición química superficial de las
estrellas de la galaxia y simplificando
muchísimo esto en medir la composición
química superficial de la estrella de la
galaxia es parecido a hacerle un examen
de sangre o quizá incluso hacerle un
examen de adn eso nos permite poner en
relación estrella distinta que quizás si
tienen la misma química puede significar
que son parientes que nacieron en la
misma región de la galaxia del mismo
tiempo mientras que estrella que tienen
química muy distinta podemos inferir
cuáles se formaron antes y cuáles
después porque tenemos una idea a lo
menos cualitativa de la evolución
química global de la galaxia
entonces yo empecé a estudiar
abundancia química de la superficie de
las estrellas que están en la parte en
el bulbo en la parte central de nuestra
galaxia unos 15 años atrás cuando empecé
el artículo más famoso sobre este tema
era este liderado por un señor que se
llama andrew make william trabaja en el
observatorio de carnegie en casa en
pasadena california
en donde habían determinado por primera
vez abundancia química detalladas de
estrellas del bulbo de nuestra galaxia
un artículo que tiene un montón de cita
y a partir de este y demás artículo
siguiente andrew williams era
considerado y sigue siendo considerado
el gurú de la abundancia química el
bulbo galáctico entonces cuando yo
empecé a trabajar en esto me convertí de
alguna manera en un competidor de
genzyme william por suerte solíamos
encontrar lo mismo resultado pero a
veces publicaba un poco ante él y a
veces publica un poco antes yo en fin
competíamos
y un lindo día mientras estoy tratando
de seleccionar estrellas en la región
central de nuestra galaxia y a la
distancia correcta para que estén en el
bulbo la estoy seleccionando para
tomarle espectro entonces medir su
abundancia química me doy cuenta que en
una dirección en particular que ahí está
marcada en verde veo algo raro
es como si en esa dirección se vieran
dos bulbo uno un poco más adelante y
otro un poco más atrás a lo largo de la
línea de visión
tengo que confesar aquí que me demore
varios meses en tomarme esto en serio al
principio dije va a ser tiene que ser
una cosa estadística una fluctuación
estadística voy a seleccionar estrella
en el medio y sigo adelante hasta que me
decidí a investigar esto un poco más y
entonces fui a buscar distinto catálogo
de esta misma región catálogo obtenido
con telescopio distinto con instrumentos
distintos y me fijé que todos ellos
tenían el mismo patrón
ahí me convencí que estaba viendo algo
real no sabía lo que era pero era real
entonces escribía una propuesta de
observación para ir a medir abundancia
química de esta estrella y tratar de
entender que estaba viendo
me dieron una noche de observación en
uno de los dos telescopios magallanes en
el observador de las campanas más o
menos cerca de la serena en chile parto
para ir a observar llegó ahí y me pidió
con dos sorpresas
la sorpresa número uno es que está
nublado y dicen que va a llover porque
si le tienen los cielos mejores del
mundo pero a veces típicamente cuando
voy a hacer varios
la segunda sorpresa es que en el
telescopio de al lado en el otro
magallanes está observando anime william
que hasta ese día yo no he encontrado
nunca en persona obviamente nos
conocemos muy bien por los artículos
pero nunca hemos hablado y bueno no va a
poder abrir el domo ninguno de los dos
esto está clarísimo entonces más vale
nos ponemos a conversar
y ahí nos pillamos por la tercera
sorpresa
andy está ahí por la misma razón que yo
él también vio algo raro que no entendió
muy parecido a lo que vi yo y pidió
tiempo de observación lo curioso que lo
asignan comité distinto así que no nos
pusieron la misma noche para propósito
nada obviamente nos quedan enganchados y
nos pasamos toda la noche comparando sus
datos con los míos tratando de razonar
que puede ser esto resulta que yo como
le contaba tengo datos muy detallados y
de distintos telescopios en una región
chiquita de nuestra galaxia
en cambio en di tiene datos de un
poquito menor calidad pero por un área
muy grande entonces poniendo estas dos
cosas juntas empezamos a entender
bastante mejor de qué se trata esto que
estamos viendo
y esto que estamos viendo es
una estructura con forma de x que yo
aquí he tratado de dibujar después la
verán mejor
por el ángulo desde el cual nosotros la
vemos desde el sol tiene una parte ay
dibuja de naranja que está delante y una
parte dibujada en azul que está detrás y
entonces en algunas direcciones por
ejemplo la que está marcada a verde
nosotros cruzamos por así decir dos
patas de la equis por esto tenemos la
impresión de ver dos bulbos
bueno en la mañana siguiente nos
devolvimos cada uno en su casa sin haber
tomado un solo dato pero con un
descubrimiento en la mochila y con un
nuevo amigo y colaborador
nos pusimos de inmediato
trabajar en un artículo que salió
publicado unos meses después en donde
decimos que vemos una estructura con
forma de x en nuestra galaxia
eso no emociona mucho porque para
empezar una cosa nueva que nadie había
sospechado pero además es gigantesca en
el cielo es realmente gigantesca y
siempre ha estado ahí y nadie la ha
vista simplemente porque es difícil ver
el bosque es mucho más difícil ver cosas
grandes que no cosas chiquitas
y además porque efectivamente tiene poco
contraste
hoy en día este resultado ha sido
confirmado por datos muy distintos y
aquí les voy a enseñar para que lo
visualicen un poco mejor
lo que hemos visto es que el bulbo de
nuestra galaxia que antes pensábamos que
fuera simplemente una barra en realidad
tiene forma de maní si se fijan como una
especie de 8 y en la parte más externa
se abre en forma de equis bien grande
y haber visto esto no solo nos hace
avanzar no hizo avanzar en el
entendimiento de la forma de nuestra
galaxia sino también es relevante porque
creemos saber cómo se forman estas
estructuras si nosotros ponemos una
simulación al computador donde solamente
ponemos el efecto de la gravedad entre
las estrellas vemos que cuando se forman
barra en el centro de la galaxia es muy
probable que esta perra empiecen a
auxiliar y den lugar a estructura con
forma de x justamente como la que hemos
visto en nuestra galaxia entonces
también hemos hecho un paso adelante
para entender cómo se ha formado por lo
menos la parte central de nuestra
galaxia entonces lo que quiero compartir
con ustedes es que he aprendido varias
cosas de esta experiencia la primera es
creerle a los datos
aun cuando no son como nosotros
esperaríamos con más razón cuando no son
como nosotros esperaríamos
y la segunda es que la colaboración es
mucho mejor más productiva y más
entretenida de la competición porque si
no se hubiese pillado esa noche un
poquito más desconfiados quizá los dos
hubiésemos pensado mejor no le cuento
nada este que he visto algo raro y que a
lo mejor tengo un descubrimiento no me
vaya a robar mi descubrimiento en cambio
por suerte no lo hicimos si hubiésemos
hecho hecho estos mismos devuelto a la
casa sin datos y sin un resultado
hay una cosa más una razón más para la
cual le tengo un cariño especial a este
artículo y es la fecha en que lo
mandamos a la revista ven usted de ahí
que lo mandamos a la revista el 26 de
julio 2010 eran días bastante especiales
para mí porque exactamente una semana
antes había visto la luz otro proyecto
muy importante de mi vida ahí está se
llama irene
y en mi hija me cuesta un poco hablar de
mi vida privada frente a tanta gente
pero siento que importante este
testimonio sobre todo para las chicas
que me escuchan porque se dice que la
maternidad puede ser un obstáculo muy
importante en el desarrollo de una
carrera científica y yo quiero
sugerirles que no se ponga en el parche
ante la herida no siempre así a mí me ha
tocado el descubrimiento más importante
de mi vida justo lo he finalizado
mientras me convertí en una madre obvio
que no siempre así quiero aclarar que
estoy en favor de cualquier acción
afirmativa que pueda soportar la
inserción de las mujeres en la academia
y en las carreras stem
pero ninguna acción afirmativa va a
tener efecto si las chicas se desaniman
de antemano
la vida es el resultado de un montón de
circunstancias la mayoría de las cuales
no es fácil prever con antelación
entonces si algo le gusta por ejemplo la
ciencia vayan a por ella la dificultad
de aparecerán y la irán resolviendo
sobre la marcha o quizá no aparecerán
pero si no lo intentan no le dan a la
vida la posibilidad de sorprenderles
como a menudo hace muchas gracias
[Aplausos]